hey guys welcome back and today we're
gonna be finishing the miniseries that
we started where we went over every
character and for honor and we discussed
kind of their abilities what they do
what to look out for how to defeat them
and other stuff regarding those
characters now like I said this is going
to be the last videos this is going to
conclude a little miniseries I'll have a
bunch of other ideas and videos coming
up after this so don't worry about that
but today's gonna be talking about the
Vanguard the very last class so let's
get into it so the first one up is gonna
be the Knights of Vanguard known as
warden wardens basically a
jack-of-all-trades type character kind
of what most of these characters are to
be honest they're pretty basic they're
nothing they don't have like a too big
of something or too small of something
whereas the assassins have a pretty
quick dash and some pretty fast attacks
the Vanguard's are pretty average but
for warden you kind of have to be weary
about a few things one of them
consisting of his double hit light
attack combo I call it where he will
swing at you from only the left and
right guard stands this attack will
never work if it's from the top but if
he swings from the right or the left and
it's a hit if he can if he presses the
right pump or the light attack button as
it hits it will be a guaranteed second
swing which kind of you've you've
probably seen it it's like a slash and
then a slash in another direction like
super quick that's what that is now you
cannot block the second attack and nor
can you dodge this you kind of just have
to take it and hopefully not gonna not
get hit by another one another thing
you're gonna have to look out for is the
crushing counter strike which when an
opponent of when a warning is facing an
opponent and he swings the opponent
swings from the top guard if he goes to
the up guard stands and presses RB at
the same exact time he basically D flex
or parries that attack and does a a
light attack swing that's or he does a
swing that's just as fast as a light
attack but doesn't the same amount of
damage as a heavy attack so also do be
very weary with the high level players
that will definitely abuse the [ __ ] out
of that so be very careful with the top
heavy attacks
another thing you want to look out for
is what everyone likes to call the
warden vortex you'll see a lot of it
it's like a heavy to a shoulder bash
heavy to a shoulder bash type of ordeal
which basically he'll just keep spamming
that until he runs out of stamina so do
be very do be aware though that if you
are near a wall you are practically
[ __ ] yourself twice there are twice
as much as you would normally have but
the only way to really counter this is
by dodging when he goes to the shoulder
bash I don't exactly know if you can
parry the attack seeing as when you when
he shoulder bashes use your stunned so I
don't exactly know if you can pair it
but if you can please let me know in the
comments below would be really great for
other people to know other than that you
really just kind of have to dodge it or
you can turn it into like a punishing
attack after the dodge and kind of drain
a few is health away so that's always a
good idea against a warden just like I
said like I'll say in the other previous
videos if you have any trouble go into a
duel pick the warden and then pick the
lowest level and that you can possibly
handle and then just keep fighting them
over and over again until gates until
you can get really better with that or
against that character so the next one
up is gonna be the viking warden or the
viking vanguard also known as Raider now
Raiders got this really slow and bought
blockable called Raiders fury which is a
zone attack which is very very slow it
can be really parried but I feel like
it's too slow to the point where you
kind of forget how fast or how slow it
is usually when people get to pit people
try to get the parrying down so that
just makes this game eve twice as easy
for them which I have no problem with
but then when Raider comes and his swing
is that slow they completely forgot how
slow it is and they try to parry before
the attack even hits him and then they
just get punished for it so do be aware
this is slower than a normal heavy
another thing you want to look out for
is he has a move where he dashes in any
direction left right or forward and
he'll do a light attack which is
basically he takes the butt end of his
little axe there and bashes your head it
will stun you and then it also makes it
even harder to block or parry
or not block it makes it even harder to
parry that unblockable attack he throws
at you so do be very careful with that a
tip is to always kind of stay in the up
guard stance as much as you can since
that stun won't connect because it's
just a light attack guard break can
really end you those who do be very
careful where you stand such as ledges
or any wall or something like that
because a guard break can basically turn
into a throw which we will throw you off
the ledge or if you're close enough he
will bring you up to a wall and bash or
take his knee and bash your head in
which will stun you so once again back
to the stunning thing it won't really
help because it will make blocking any
unblockable or guarding any unblockable
like twice as hard so ones of the last
event guard and the last character for
the series Ken say so Mackenzie's moves
comes to consist of the Helms footer and
the swift strike which are he died he
will dash forward and then press RB to
do a little chop on your head which is
the helm strike or he will dash to the
left or right and swing in that general
direction and that is called the swift
strike now the way to kind of guess
where he's swinging cuz the blade goes
back and then it goes forward like
obviously if he's swinging but it looks
like he's coming from the left when he's
really going to the right depending on
which way he's going what you wanted to
do is whatever direction he dashes just
to guard that because you will block
that swift strike immediately and for
the helm splitter which is the dash
forward and RB hit that looks like a
kind of a jab you kind of just have to
predict you know the more you play
against the Ken so you'll kind of
realize that they start to use that a
lot more often so dashing forward
hitting usually when they dash forward
this is about a 50-50 chance they'll
either try to guard break you or they
will try to do a helm splitter attack
which then leads into my next point
about the grasping pounce or when he
dashes forward and presses X it's like a
normal guard break but it has a lot more
range than a normal guard right seeing
as you're dashing forward so you do have
some more time with it he also has three
unblockable combos that will all that
will all add in like I said into an
unblockable attack which is always from
the
top guard so do be aware of those three
he can do what's called a soft feint
where when he loads up that unblockable
he can if he switches stances with the
right thumbstick
and then or whatever you happen to play
on I play an Xbox so he switches with
the right thumbstick and then clicks the
right bumper it will stop the right
trigger unblockable and then immediately
switch to a light attack which throws
off so many players if it's landed so
that is going to happen too so if you
start facing some high level Ken's a so
do be aware of that I hope you guys did
enjoy though this is going to conclude
our little series I hope this was fun
for you all and I hope if you guys
enjoyed the video please leave a like if
you see if this is your newest video you
know subscribe to the channel and all
that I'm sorry if I didn't sound too
great or kind of like slur my words a
bit I did it's I'm so tired right now
I'm going to bed as soon as I'm done
with this [ __ ] so I'll see you all later
guys and peace out